oh happy thursday america
we're almost at the end of the week and
if you're like me you're probably really
attractive
so sometimes when a crime is committed
we focus on the main perps but not the
accessories
except that in the world of cover-ups
and politics it's the accessories who
sealed the deal i speak of the 51
so-called intelligence operatives who
signed a widely lauded document claiming
hunter biden's laptop could be russian
disinformation the key words being could
be
yeah and i could be a bottle of ketchup
but that doesn't mean you can turn me
upside down and spank my bottom
well you can but you have to ask me
first
sorry bill
when the statement came out every
talking head who wanted trump gone
pointed to it like it was the ten
commandments and james clapper was moses
without the cool beard or the hair but
now republicans are saying these spooks
should expect subpoenas next year if
they don't tell us how they reached
their wrong conclusions in unison
without any evidence and with the
accuracy of miss cleo deep into a bottle
of scotch
since after all it helped the biden
campaign kill pre-election coverage of
emails linking joe to his son's business
ventures in china and ukraine as well as
contact info for hookers and crackheads
and other people who still owe me money
it's incredible when you think about it
the media the democratic party and our
intel services working together like a
shadow government one that unlike our
actual government ruthlessly gets things
done they joined like siamese triplets
decided how to disappear a story and how
to amplify the lie and ultimately they
got americans to vote they went the way
they wanted them to vote i hope they
said cnn msnbc and the good people at 60
minutes thank you cards
and now a year and a half after killing
the story they're verifying the data
from tax fraud to foreign lobbying cri
crimes but why now
because it serves a purpose
tell us wise man
they suppressed it to get him in now
they're releasing it to get him out
how does that guy keep getting younger
three words carrot smoothie enemas
but he makes a good point
they manipulated the biden laptop story
like a spigot they needed joe to get
elected so they turned it off and now
that he's become an albatross around the
party's neck they're turning it up but
some holdouts think it's still really
nothing
my problem with hunter biden's laptop is
i think totally irrelevant i mean it's
not whether it's disinformation or i
mean i don't think the
hunter biden's
business relationships have anything to
do with who should be president of the
united states so
i didn't find i don't find it to be
interesting oh it's not interesting it's
the same way i think about that time in
that mexican prison wasn't interesting
of course he's not into it why cover a
story that makes you look so bad a
question the view producers should ask
their hosts every morning in fact there
should be a service dedicated to when
the mainstream media looks stupid they
could call it cnn plus
speaking of here's a great moment from a
symposium of disinformation when a
bright kid asks brian stelter exactly
what we've all been asking
you've all spoken extensively about fox
news being a purveyor of
disinformation
but cnn is right up there with them they
pushed the russian collusion hoax they
pushed the jesse smallett hoax they
smeared justice kavanaugh as a rapist
and they also smeared nick salmon as a
white supremacist and yes they dismissed
the hunter biden laptop affair as pure
russian disinformation
with mainstream corporate journalists
becoming little more than
apologists and cheerleaders for the
regime is it time to finally declare
that the uh
the canon of journalistic ethics is dead
or no longer operative uh all the
mistakes of the mainstream media and cnn
in particular seem to magically all go
in one direction are we expected to
believe that this is all just some sort
of random coincidence or is there
something else behind it
it's too bad it's time for lunch
it's always lunch with that guy
the weird thing is it was only eight in
the morning
[Laughter]
so now the belated verification raises
fresh questions about these 51 people
who are they
why did they do it they're so mysterious
you'd think they were from area 51.
the media didn't think this through and
neither did these dupes they forgot
about what happens later when you get
caught or maybe they did but are
convinced they're untouchable like
hillary and the rest of the democratic
ratback either way they claim the new
york post article was part of a russian
disinfo operation
so now let's see the paper trail let's
follow the money let's see the names of
all the people who helped create the
statement that includes all the big
names like john brennan and leon panetta
and michael hayden and of course the
ironically named james clapper who's
never done anything worthy of applause
they saw no real evidence yet they said
the russians did it
the technical term for that is making
up and now the new york post has
published a piece showing the 12 times
joe biden took part in hunter biden's
business dealings showing that the big
guy was more alert in these shenanigans
than he is at his own press conferences
saying he didn't is like saying mike
lindell had nothing to do with my pillow
i wonder when the new york times or the
washington post will decide that this is
finally real will they wait 18 months i
wonder what joe thinks
hey hey hey look look come on man
here's the deal yeah i mean
your son needs help you help him out
that's the way i do things all right
think about it if your son likes
baseball needs work on his fastball you
throw a few around right
if he uh if he likes making money from
corrupt regimes in eastern europe you
know you throw him a bone
it's what i do i'm the big guy look
here's the deal you know
to be honest i thought
if he made a couple of suitcases full of
cash maybe he'd uh you know lose the bad
habits
well we know how that turned out man
and it cuts in the cradle and the silver
spoon when you're coming home on i don't
know when
wow so the cover-up was meant to sway an
election by misleading the american
voters worse they weren't relying on
evidence but exploiting their esteemed
resumes in national security experience
and now they may be subject to a
congressional investigation
it's ironic these intelligence officials
did not see this coming where's the
intelligence in that it's like a palm
reader getting hit by a bus
let's welcome tonight's guess
if he serves as attorney general one
more time he gets a free blizzard at
dairy queen former attorney general of
the united states and author of the
great new book one damn thing after
another billboard
and if you think his jacket is cheesy
wait till you hear his jokes
box across americo's jimmy fella
yes
and she's the reason houses in detroit
cost a dollar
fox news contributor cat tim
and finally
elephants don't want to talk about the
tyrus in the room
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrus yo
so bill welcome to the show can i call
you bill sure awesome are you any
regrets so far
you all right no i'm happy okay good
you're happy yeah we put something in
the water
you might wake up somewhere else you
might wake up on outnumbered
god help you so what are you what are
you um what's your take on the media
coverage and all this i know you can't
really talk about the cases
this is the
simply a gross example of something
that's done on a daily basis by the
media and when you talk about all this
hand-wringing that was done over foreign
interference in the election
this kind of thing has far greater
impact yeah yeah yeah and it's i think
the impact too at least for somebody
like me and people of other attractive
people
[Laughter]
you
you um
i can't believe anything anymore i'm
doubting i'm even doubting pictures you
know like oh maybe that's a deep fake so
we're all we've all become maybe it's
healthy that we've become cynical what
do you think
no i don't think so i mean uh
you know people have to have faith in
not only elections they also
feel that we were all operating from
some common
set of facts right to make decisions
yeah and then we find out we're not much
like your jacket you stop it it looks
like a beehive exploded
you know it's a funny story that no one
knows i actually saw you out to dinner
the other night with your wife but i
didn't want to interrupt you because she
was waiting uh asking the waiter for a
booster seat and uh
it was contentious and i didn't want to
screw it up uh but we can talk about
this because i want to talk about it and
i love you so good to see you um
it's so good
uh like first of all the idea that
anyone at the atlantic
the idea that anyone at the atlantic is
lecturing about the dangers of
misinformation right that's like someone
at high times lecturing about the
dangers of marijuana yes i'm like yo
that's your whole magazines yeah it's
not even an ocean it's a magazine and
they call themselves the atlantic thank
you these are the same dirt bags if you
remember yes who ran the anonymously
sourced report on trump's slandering
veterans with 23 people on record
denying it they were still willing to
run the story but in this instance they
won't cover the story with a mountain of
evidence not to mention dna john
radcliffe saying it was legit before the
election not to mention his business
partner tony bobolinsky saying it's a
thing yeah let's be very clear everybody
watching at home there is no world where
hunter biden gets this money without his
dad being vice president no one is
sitting in a corporate boardroom trying
to boost profits going you know we need
a guy who's been thrown out of the
chateau marmont for doing too much drugs
that's going to boost profits right
there you know what you got to do to get
kicked out of the chateau marmont i've
tried stop it that's like you can't be a
kardashian anymore too many selfies yeah
you can't do it anymore yeah
yeah you know tyrus uh joe did say
something he said there was not a
scintilla
of evidence of improper and improper
behavior and he's right it was an
avalanche it's not a that's cintilla by
the way cintilla is like a shred of
evidence i go by police
just real quick how dare you he doesn't
get booster seats grow up man he has a
high chair
yes
tag team he finally tagged him with me
no it was just because i wasn't he said
beehive and clearly somebody knit that
i think
what we we have to know we have to
understand where they're coming from yes
these are great american martyrs
they couldn't have what happened in the
previous election where hillary's
laundry came out right right at the
finish line
and oh no it's gonna happen again yeah
so
they all fell on their swords
to save the country
from high
yeah
problems
[Laughter]
like
everything falling to
if he gets in but they kept him out
yeah and we're all knee-deep in it now
so job well done that's such a great
point they they
saw this as a heroic deed never mind
never mind the forget the consequences
this is the immorality but we'll worry
about that later we just got to make
sure that the red dragon doesn't get in
there yes and because everything's going
to be better there's going to be no
inflation no
horrible economics no crime no wars yes
it's pretty much everything they accused
him was of was going to happen if he was
in
happened
when they got in yeah and when he got
out yes yeah
quick pro
whatever yeah
you're a lawyer aren't you tyrus
yeah i don't have to be for this one
you know uh
i had a rough day today i had i drank
some bad wine last night so yeah we know
thanks for the texas yeah
did i text you
oh yes i did anyway
cat uh joe james biden james biden got
like 17 a 17 million dollar wire from
china
and then there was like a 150 other
weird wires going on and yet ann
applebaum thinks this is a really boring
story you got drugs that's it that's
exactly it i thought i'd heard the worst
takes ever on this already but to call
this not interesting
okay
smoking crack with escorts stripper baby
mamas we as a country find that
interesting or we would not be on season
31 of maury that is just a fact and i
don't think that's again the most you
know important part about any of this if
you want to smoke crack and knock up
strippers that's between you and your
doctor
but
i take chances
it's the corruption part that might be
that i think is you know the
potential corruption looking at this
that is the part that i think really
matters but don't say it's not
interesting when there's crack and
escorts and stripper baby mamas
one of those yes and it's interesting to
me and i got everything i wanted all he
needed was a guitar yeah you could play
the guitar he had sex drugs and rock and
roll and it would be interesting yeah
you got to have all three
there's a nickname the big guy yes
that's everything you need to know the
big guy what made watergate deep throat
we got the big guy could have been chris
christie thank you there you go
oh he was building a bridge in jersey
yeah
shut it down yeah all right that's
enough up next violence and looting they
espouse and spend 6 million on a house
that was a good rhyme well done
everybody hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else